[Music]  scientists believe that writing found on  an ancient papyrus could be proof that  Jesus actually had a wife check that out  yes interesting well ladies and  gentlemen we have something better than  a scroll to prove that Jesus was married  don't ask us how we actually have very  rare footage  very rare footage that's right that's  right  footage of jesus's domestic life we've  founded ourselves we're archaeologists  take a look hey why can you take the  garbage out yes Jesus I meant pick it up  and take it to the curb why do you care  how I did it I took the trash out get  some exercise stop using your mat so you  like my magic when I turn your water  into sharknado you're the worst  you're the worst oh Jesus  [Applause]  it turned into a butterfly the hell was  that